we did a segment last week before
thanksgiving might have been the week
before
um about how fox news has been so
effective at radicalizing their own
viewers
that fox news viewers are now turning on
fox
because fox isn't radical enough and the
context was election results as you saw
there are some fox anchors chris wallace
neil cavuto
eric shawn they acknowledge that joe
biden won the election
and you saw furious trump supporters
abandon fox
along with trump himself promoting even
more radical and farcical news sources
oan
and newsmax and our friend molly jong
fast
wrote a piece about this in the daily
beast it's worth checking out it's
called fox news is no longer
insane enough for fox viewers
and she writes they built a huge outrage
machine
then some of them tried to be real news
people for five minutes
and now the outrage machine is outraged
at them
this is the irony i think the phrase
that applies is
if you fly too close to the sun you will
get burned or something like that
they created this they told their
audience you can't trust the media when
they say things that don't sound right
about right wingers and you've got to be
outraged when you were told those things
and now their viewers are seeing fox
sometimes report accurately that joe
biden won
and so they're furious with fox and they
don't trust
fox and they're looking for something
else they were chanting fox news sucks
at various protests over the election
results in the days after the november
third election
and molly writes in this article quote
but the problem is that fox had built an
audience that had gotten more and more
radicalized with each passing
year by fox's content so by election
night
when fox anchor suddenly wanted to play
things straight it created a phenomenon
whereby fox news was unable to keep up
with the conservative
outrage generated by fox news
and this is exactly right and part of it
is that you still have on fox news
itself people promoting and supporting
trump's voter fraud theories
this is part of the radicalization fox's
opinion
people have radicalized their viewers
against
anyone telling them trump lost it just
so happens there are also people on fox
news telling them that trump lost
we looked at clips earlier from maria
bartoromo indistinguishable
from a north korean state media anchor
reporting news about kim jong-un
and at the same time we have eric shawn
saying oh well
biden won and there's no evidence of the
fraud trump claims exist
so this is where we start wondering
about the future of fox
you might see a fracturing of the agenda
setters in right-wing media where fox
news
sets the agenda maybe for what we'd call
more traditional reactionary ideas
and then the stuff of the last few weeks
the q anon stuff the types protesting
elections
they maybe fracture off to oan or
newsmax
it may all change after january 20th
when joe biden is elected
it all remains to be seen but the
important takeaway here is
fox itself is to blame for this at least
in part
they created a safe space for fact-free
baseless nonsense for years which they
attempted to present as news this is the
bed that they have made
and maybe they will suffer financially
from it i don't know
but it will be very interesting to see
what the right-wing media landscape
looks in for example
six months a few months into joe biden's
presidency
once vaccines have been rolled out for
coronavirus
where will the conspiracies lie what
will fox look like
what will oan and newsmax look like we
can only wait and see
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service
at privacy.com pacman privacy is a
service i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your
real card number stays completely
private
and you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
pacman